In the graph, we can talk about something called an Eulerian path.
This is the path that starts off with some node on the graph, let's say A in this case.
And it moves along the edges from node to node,
hitting every edge exactly once, and then ending it from node to the graph.
In this case, we have an Eulerian path that's started at A and ended with D.
Euler by the way was a famous mathematician, Leonhard Euler.
He made a number of contributions to discrete math and ultimately, computer science.
Here's something that we can notice about a graph.
If it has a Eulerian path, notice what has to happen to all the nodes along the path.
Here's what we did in this example, we went from A to B, to D, to A, to C, to D.
Now let's consider the degree of all the nodes in the graph.
A has a degree of 3, B has a degree of 2, D has a degree of 3, and C has a degree of 2.
Notice that these nodes B and C, which were not either at the beginning or ending of the path,
the Eulerian path, have an even degree and that has to be.
What happens if all the nodes that are not in the beginning and ending nodes
have to had even degree because the path has to go in one edge and out another edge.
Every time that node gets passed through, 2 of the edges are visited,
and none of them are visited twice and none of them are skipped.
So it has to be that all these nodes that are intermediate on the path have even degree.
The beginning and ending nodes are different though.
If the path starts off at A and leaves A along one of the edges and that consumes one of those edges.
The beginning and ending nodes, A and D in this case, have to have odd degree
because, in addition to any times that the path moves through them and comes up the other side,
it either leaves in the beginning or enters at the end without a corresponding other side.
Those have to be odd, all the other ones have to be even.
It turns out that this relationship is in "if and only if"--that is to say if the graph is connected
and has exactly 2 odd degree nodes, then it has an Eulerian path, and if not, then it doesn't.
Now, there is one exception to this. What if all of the nodes in the graph are even degree?
Let's take a quick look at a special case here.
Here is a graph with 5 nodes and the degree of all of the nodes is even--2, 4, 2, 4, and 2.
Can a graph like this with only even degree nodes have an Eulerian path?
One possible answer is no, the start and the end edges of the path had to have odd degree,
which is the ruling in this case, so it can't have an Eulerian path.
Another possible answer is yes, but it depends on the particulars of the graph in question.
Some graphs with only even degree nodes have Eulerian paths and some don't.
Another possibility is that the answer is yes, all such graphs do.
Any graph that's connected and has only even degree nodes
will have an Eulerian path in a particular form.
Another possible answer is yes, because all graphs do.
You can't really have a graph that doesn't have an Eulerian path.